[Musica]
oggi siamo su un horror credo sia un
horror è una demo proviamo ecco se già
abile di far vomitare durante il menù
non ci siamo capiti
oggi giochiamo a seven io non sono
supposta per stare in questa homestay
non dovrei stare in questa casa è
posseduta quindi per favore dio aiutami
partiamo che siamo sui poster dei dei
metallica
ok per quale motivo spiegano il motivo
di break cioè non capisco il senso pro
ottimi gusti musicali
almeno quello di non sto dormendo grazie
di avermelo ricordato no perché non
avevo notato noto come le porte si
aprono con una lentezza è un dettaglio
nelle ombre soprattutto tanta del
dettaglio delle ombre quando si apre la
porta e preciso proprio mentre la
portasse apre l'ombra preciso
ok che è successo non ho capito questo è
successo ho sentito un rumore brutto e
c'è una mensola veramente orribile
incorporata nel muro fax blocks è la
portata poi sono entrato come si esce il
sun ray dio grazie per delizia ilsa
sedia almeno e musicali sono buoni il
gioco fa schifo ma il gusti musicali wow
non mi copyright aree il video per
cortesia aprì la porta non fa chi slot
fakis copyright
ah ok
volevo fare una battuta su bocelli ma ho
lasciato perdere meno male bene sono
contento che la porta ci sia riaperta
grazie avermi ha fatto ascoltare buona
musica nel mentre non c'è niente nella
lavatrice mentre nella vostra viglia
niente nel lavandino
c'è una cosa nel frigo dove la nutella
non c'è la nutella c'è qualcosa in
questo gioco schifoso maledizione c'è
un'altra stanza uguale a prima non ti
chiudere per favore grazie si apre solo
questo però gli altri sono gli altri
sono finti va bene traccia mia tricase
si apre solo qualche assetto vabbè
andiamo di qua o un televisore posso
vedere qualcosa posso provare ad uscire
golden gate 7 numeri ha perso anche
scrivere non era la password per aprire
la porta peccato ma se la password
numerica perché mi fai scrivere delle
cose chiave a preti messo una
segretissima di password
harry potter lupus in tabula quante
probabilità ci sono di azzeccare
esattamente il numero non ci sono gli
avanti le persone oggigiorno
preferiscono scrollare i loro telefoni
invece che è leggere i libri triste ma
vero invece che leggere botta che c'è
molle il libro dei pokémon sfocato è
avanti 4 a eve laico e della password da
password 4 solo un 4 metto
hai visto ci sono sette i quattro è solo
il primo giorno con un miliardo mi deve
rimanere lì 4 tutto il tempo va bene ma
c'è una porta qua non l'avevo vista
quindi devo trovare i così in in giro
che mi dicono ma non è disponibile nella
demo scusa mi va bene allora niente
niente disponente demo peccato volevo
andare di sopra allora la mettere
neanche alla porta che questo pure una
demo no perché il giocata mente bello
che lo vogliono fare completo dunque 4
la cosa che mi chiedo come fanno ad
esserci 7 cose da digitare eccolo qua
come fanno essercene 7 se la casa è
minuscola impossibile ci hanno visto
solo uno a stento tra l'altro come fanno
esserci nel sette e assurdo 4 3 3 la
formazione dell'inter
quindi quando prendi un bigliettino ne
compare un altro in tutta la casa
questo è il gioco ha sì ok ne compaiono
altri in giro ogni volta ne prendi uno
va bene questo non me lo per questo lo
lasciamo qui 43 39
eccolo compaiono randomicamente 4 3 3 9
ne mancano in teoria 21 sicuramente qua
eccolo da 57 eccola l'ultima parco
lemonia che saresti tu prese spacebar
rapidi lì lo premuta a posto c'era una
tizia bruttissima 4 3 3 95 79 e stato un
piacere è stato un piacere ma non è che
non sia uscita al televisore perché
sarei potuto morire di infarto ancora
peggio però mi fa piacere che ci siano
questi individui 33 95 79 bang
[Musica]
ha giocato a un gioco o brutto forse era
meglio spara subito
non so fare le rime vada a catturare
mister mi è molto carino quindi ragazzi
faceva veramente vomitare era un gioco
stupido e facciamo un altro signori
siamo sul gioco un po fatto meglio
secondo me scp con tenda intrecciano
visto ho visto che l'hanno aggiornato
era vecchis ceprini telo rifiuti in
genera una mappa tipo minecraft horror
con gente horror che ti segue che fa le
cose se conosce il segreto di melo qui
si rade con un coltello affilatissimo i
peli del petto e con quel coltello ci ha
fatto anche dei panini che io ho
mangiato vado a lavarmi i denti subito
dopo questo video oh che bello allora e
non mi ricordo l'ultima volta che ci ho
giocato sarà stato 6000 anni fa
buongiorno dicevo il suo gioco quando
c'è brent succedono cos'è randomiche
quello che vedete è randomico che io
sappia
ogni volta un avventore diverso e che
fighissimo gli occhi si chiudono dopo un
po da soli perché devi sbattere le
palpebre cioè una cosa molto strana però
ci sono dei degli scp che sono questi
mostri che sono all'interno di questo
bunker nell'area 51 lo so dove si tosto
luca non ho idea e alcuni non li devi
guardare negli occhi cioè non so come
funziona con invece devi fissarli di
continuo perché sono ti ammazzano il
gioco prodotto allegro permesso dove
devo andare di preciso io vado avanti
c'è un sacco di fantasia sul posto o
delle scale livello 1
dovrei mandare a quello dopo e mi piace
il fatto che ci sarà quindi le scale
possono portare a tutti i livelli
fighissimo quindi ho trovato le scale
sono contento il livello 3 andiamo
nell'ultimo aosta nevicando
che figata c'e l'uscita c'è uscita da
ben si vede fuori che bello non sono
lamentazioni di penombra tra l'altro
cos'è sta roba da poco demo io mi sono
pagato per soldi saltasse addosso al
momento all'altro ma non è aprile io li
faceva aprire gli anni signori c'è un
problema
chiudi chiudi la porta poteva venir bene
avere non ho capito cosa è successo ma
c'era un coso che si che emergerà dal
poi dal terreno sono morto cos'è
successo
non ho capito niente rifacciamo non ho
capito nulla è uscita una roba dal muro
e io dovrei conoscere bene tutti i
mostri di questo gioco per riuscire a
contrastarli capitano lo conosco ormai
neanche uno non ne conosco anzi facciamo
così leggiamo cina guida veloce
ok a quanto pare ce ne sono molto di più
di quanto pensassi pazienza vediamo
vediamo poi più avanti come contrastare
la gente adesso giochiamo avevi proprio
è cambiato completamente che figata
facile la roba una macchinetta del caffè
goffi no ap si confermi nato che faccio
attivato colpo se non devo attivare
scherzavo 6 co attivato un portico
demonio
non sono stato io c'ero schiacciato in
tasca non volevo ho fatto qualcosa non
so cosa va bene ma tu puoi sopravvivere
in questo gioco c'è puoi uscire
effettivamente sarebbe molto figo se tu
potessi farlo vorrei andare di nuovo a
livello 3 perché mi sa che il livello
più vicino all'uscita anche se non so se
esiste l'uscita qualcuno che ci gioca
molto spesso perché so che giocatissimo
come gioco mi dice se l'uscita esiste
c'è una papera
sicuramente ora sono salvo venite se
esiste un uscita se sono scemo io ho
finalmente non prenderne più di due per
favore prendi di tutte perché non è vero
sto perdendo vita come ho perso le mani
cosa come avevo scherzavo non prendete
mai più di due caramelle se non ce
l'avete nel corpo bene io che volevo
fare il figo e prendere più di due
colonie apre la porta non aprile vari
non posso aprirla sono morto
sono morto dissanguato mi hanno ucciso
delle caramelle da ioan tutti i modi cui
potrò morire con delle caramelle sono
morti non è non prendiamo le più di due
perché sennò mi si stacca le mani io non
capisco le cose che succedono in cui non
le capisco no no a e tipo la camera gola
di auto la sensi ha preso solo è una
camera di che conta decontaminazione
io so solo come si contrasta uno di
questi anche delle scale solo come si
condiscono si contrasta 1 distimo
stregua che è quello dove devi fissarlo
continuamente e non perdere mai il
contatto fisico sono ti salta in bocca
solo quello so come si contrasta che poi
penso sia il principio il nemico
principale di sc p ma noi ci credo è
cosa che si chiama hai una v the guy sta
giocando a vergona peter green va bene
proprio il gioco più sbagliato giocare
in questo momento figlio finalmente un
qualcosa di allegro salve lei è signor
giovanni fammi vedere un attimo cosa
proprio carino thomas cantica sotto la
tua una schematica fia.mi ha via via via
via via via apri porco demonio porco
porco demonio chiudi la porta la porta a
chi la porta va là non ci credo è
passato mi sono chiuso dentro mi sono
chiuso dentro sono un deficiente
salve salve la vita lei sorride almeno
quello signori io non ho capito come si
gioca sta roba
però che vi sia piaciuto non so come
trattare la gente però almeno il tipo e
sorridente ho fatto anche la vita ma se
i ragazzi avete piaciuto il documento
gli piace anche una risorsa comitato
transizione senza questi schiavi
ci vediamo l'anno prossimo visto dai
ragazzi
[Musica]
no